[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Heinz
Wolf und Marietta Slomka guten Abend
dass man den Wasserhahn aufdreht und
kein Tropfen aus der Leitung kommt das
kennt man in unseren Breitengraden ja
eigentlich nicht außer wenn es im Haus
Klempner arbeiten oder ähnliches gibt in
anderen europäischen Ländern zum
Beispiel Frankreich gab es das hingegen
schon Trinkwasser moderationiert oder
sogar zeitweise abgestellt in manchen
Gegenden wurde sogar verboten
Leitungswasser zu trinken oder sich
damit die Zähne zu putzen weil die
Wasserqualität nicht mehr ausreichend
gewährleistet war ein solcher
Trinkwassermangel droht im Zuge des
Klimawandels auch auf Deutschland
zuzukommen und dabei ist die private
Wasserversorgung nur ein Teil des
Problems die Bundesregierung will mit
einer nationalen wasserstrategie
gegenhalten
Strausberg östlich von Berlin wer
hierher zieht muss sich zum Wasser
sparen verpflichten der Verbrauch ist
gedeckelt bei zu viel Entnahme drohen
Strafzahlungen die Gemeinde wächst das
benachbarte neue tesla-werk muss
mitversorgt werden der Wasserverband
fürchtet deshalb um die
Versorgungssicherheit wir sehen die
Wasserverfügbarkeit Trinkwasser
Verfügbarkeit als limitieren den Faktor
das ist eine Situation die wir in
Deutschland so alle nicht kennen die
relativ neu ist für uns alle weil wir
natürlich alle mit dem Gedanken
aufgewachsen sind Wasser ist immer da
für alle
24/7 angesichts von Wetter extremen und
Dürren wird Wasser noch wertvoller die
Bundesregierung beschließt heute die
erste nationale wasserstrategie
langfristige Vorsorge für wasserärmere
Zeiten wir müssen uns auf die Änderungen
der Klimakrise vorbereiten und uns daran
anpassen dass das Wasser da Gebot ein
anderes sein wird sich die Zeiten
verändern und sich die
Mengen verändern die Strategie bündelt
eine Vielzahl von Maßnahmen bei
Wasserknappheit sollen jetzt
bundeseinheitliche Leitlinien gelten
auch wird geprüft wo wasserarme Gebiete
per Fernleitungen versorgt werden können
und Wasser Reinigungskosten sollen
fairer zwischen Privathaushalten und
Industrie verteilt werden
Wasser ist für
Umweltbewegungen kritisieren gerade
große Konzerne würden in der neuen
Strategie zu stark geschont
dürfen auch
wasserentnahmerechter nicht mehr über
Jahrzehnte hinweg vergeben werden das
ist gerade der Fall sondern sie müssen
eigentlich stetig evaluiert werden im
Kontext des Klimawandels ob das
überhaupt noch möglich ist so viel
Wasser zu entnehmen weil sonst eben im
schlimmsten Fall für die Bevölkerung
nichts mehr übrig bleibt im Wasser
Haushaltsgesetz steht ja schon heute
dass die öffentliche da seins Vorsorge
Priorität hat dazu gehört eben auch die
Versorgung von wirtschaftlichen Nutzern
mit Wasser mit Wasser aber für eine
mangelage würde es dann eine
Priorisierung zugunsten des Trinkwassers
geben müssen
in vielen Ländern Europas ist es gerade
viel zu trocken eine Winter Dürre lässt
Flüsse verschwinden sehen vertrocknen
gerade der Regen jetzt wäre wichtig für
die Landwirtschaft stattdessen taumeln
die Bauern von Dürre zu Dürre
in Deutschland erholt sich der Boden
gerade vom zu heißen Sommer trotzdem
zeigt der dürre-monitor noch immer viele
rote viele trockene Regionen im tiefen
Boden bleibt das Defizit
winterdorn hatten wir bisher in den
letzten Jahren gar nicht wir haben immer
als Glück gehabt dass ich im Winter
wieder wenigstens die obere Schicht des
Bodens durch Nest deswegen ist das was
dort in Frankreich stattfindet im Moment
eine ganz neue Qualität wenn das hier
auftreten würde zusammen mit einer
Sommer hätten wir sehr große Probleme
ständig sauberes und bezahlbares Wasser
das sei ein Privileg so heißt es bei der
Vorstellung der Strategie heute
deutlicher wird das mit jeder Dürre
ja das wollen wir mit Carsten Rinke vom
Helmholtz-Zentrum für Umweltforschung in
Magdeburg noch weiter vertiefen guten
Abend Herr Rinke
ich grüße Sie Frau Slomka wenn man
Experten wie ihnen zuhört dann muss man
schon den Eindruck haben die Zeiten wo
man sich keine Gedanken mehr darüber
machen musste wo Wasser herkommt und
Opfer da ist die die sind vorbei das
wird ein richtig knappes Gut oder
Wasser ist die Ressource Nummer eins und
unser wichtigstes Lebensmittel das ist
auf jeden Fall etwas worüber man sich
Gedanken machen kann und sollte und
deswegen stimme ich ihn da voll und ganz
zu gibt es ja verschiedene Überlegungen
wie man die Problematik in den Begriff
bekommt was was wäre da für sie die
wichtigste Maßnahme das wichtigste
Instrument ist die nachhaltige
Gestaltung des
landschaftswasserhaushaltes es geht also
nicht nur darum die anthropogenen
Nutzung zu ermöglichen in der Zukunft
der Naturräume
schön Sie dass ich da jetzt unterwegs
menschlichen Nutzung das heißt ja das
heißt das Wasser das wir brauchen für
die Trinkwasserversorgung für
industrielle Nutzung Brauchwasser und in
Zukunft auch viel stärker für die
Bewässerung nebenbei bemerkt dass neben
diesen wasserbedarfen eben auch der
Naturraum ein Bedarf hat einfach um die
Ökosysteme am Leben zu halten die
terrestrischen wie die aquatischen um
die landwirtschaftliche Produktivität
aufrecht zu erhalten um den Wald zu
stabilisieren und genau solche Tendenzen
wie wir sie anders vor beobachten zum
Beispiel mediterranen Raum also die
Versteppung oder großflächige
Waldverluste
weitestgehend zu vermeiden also wenn Sie
diese Landwirtschaft ansprechen umso
heißer ist wird umso mehr werden ja
Landwirte eigentlich Wasser verbrauchen
um Ihre Pflanzen überhaupt noch zu
retten das ist ja eigentlich ein Dilemma
wie wie kommt man da raus indem man was
ganz anderes anpflanzt in Zukunft
das ist eines der großen fragen wir
werden in Zukunft einen höheren
Wasserbedarf der Landwirtschaft erleben
da ich zeitig ist gerade im Sommer wenn
also die landwirtschaftlichen Produkte
auf dem Felde wachsen das Wasser da
Gebot schlechter in Zukunft weil es
wärmer wird und damit Trockner
andere Früchte sind eine Option wir
werden sicherlich auch in vielen
Gebieten Deutschlands mit Bewässerung
arbeiten müssen wenn wir die Landwirt
wenn wir die landwirtschaftliche
Produktion aufrechterhalten wollen wo
drauf wir ja angewiesen sind wir sollten
uns schon selber versorgen können
und da spielt eine große Rolle wie man
bewässert im Moment wird sowieso nur ein
sehr kleiner Teil unserer Nutzfläche
bewässert also drei bis fünf Prozent in
Zukunft werden wir den Faktor 5 bis 10
mehr an Fläche bewässern und das muss
wesentlich effizienter gestaltet werden
das ist möglich technische Lösungen sind
vorhanden schauen Sie mal nach Israel
oder andere Bereiche gerade der
mediterranen Raum man kann auch mit
weniger Wasser die gleiche Produktion
erreichen und wir werden vermutlich auch
Regenwasser anders nutzen müssen also
wenn man wird sich vielleicht auch daran
gewöhnen das große Zisternen überall
eingebaut werden auch in den auch in den
Städten oder nur auf dem Land die
Regenwasser Nutzung ist ein ganz
essentieller Punkt und dabei geht es
nicht nur darum dass Wasser aufzufangen
und eben gerade irgendwelche Nutzung
zuzuführen sondern es geht vor allen
Dingen darum dass der Regen im Boden
versickern kann wir verlieren viel zu
viel unseres Regenwassers durch die
schnelle Ableitung ist das Wasser einmal
im Fluss ist es zwei Wochen später oder
eine Woche später im Meer und damit
verloren das Wasser muss in den Boden
der ist Grundwasser ist der größte
Speicher den wir haben im Land und den
gilt es maximal aufzufüllen deswegen ist
regenwassermanagement eines der großen
Instrumente die auch in der
wasserstrategie angesprochen sind und
das betrifft natürlich auch den
urbanenraum denn der urbanenraum leidet
ja gerade unter diesen hohen
versiegelungsanteil die dazu führen dass
das Wasser viel zu schnell abgeleitet
wird was uns ja an anderen Stellen auch
wieder Probleme macht weil zum Beispiel
die Abwassersysteme dadurch bei
Starkregen überlastet werden oder wir
auch Hochwasser Probleme haben eine
Versickerung des Wassers
löst auch andere Probleme
aber es schafft natürlich auch auf
welche dieser ganze Wasserknappheit dass
man ahnt ja dass es da auch zu
Verteilungskämpfen kommen wird wer
kriegt welche Wasseranteile wenn das
nicht mehr unendlich vorhanden ist ja
wir rechnen mit Nutzungskonflikten und
hier ist es ganz wichtig regional zu
differenzieren Deutschland ist zwar
insgesamt immer noch im Weltvergleich
ein recht wasserreiches Land aber in
sich doch sehr heterogen gerade der
Osten oder mitteldeutsche Raum ist
äußerst trocken während in Teile im ja
im rheinischen Gebiet eigentlich eher
unter der hochwasserproblematik leiden
wenn wir dort über das Thema Wasser
sprechen deswegen muss man das regional
ausdifferenzieren und tatsächlich jetzt
Konzepte und auch Vorstellungen
entwickeln und absprechen wie gehen wir
mit Notsituation um wie kontingentieren
und priorisieren wir das Wasser wir
brauchen diese Pläne in der Schublade
damit wir sie dann rausziehen können und
anwenden können denn wir müssen schnell
reagieren in diesen Laden da kommt noch
was auf uns zu herrinke ich danke für
das Gespräch
welche politischer Sprengstoff im Klima
und Umweltschutz steckt letztlich gerade
auch in den Niederlanden beobachten die
kleine Niederlande ist eine der größten
agrarexporteure der Welt die
holländischen Tomaten kennt natürlich
jeder die Tulpen sowieso ein wichtiger
Bereich ist auch die vielhaltung Fleisch
Milch Käse mit der idyllischen Frau
Antje aus Holland hat das aber wenig zu
tun das sind intensivbetriebe die große
Mengen Ammoniak produzieren und die
Böden vergiften gegen Umweltauflagen die
nicht zuletzte Europäische Gerichtshof
einforderte erhebt sich in der
Bauernschaft allerdings massiver Protest
der sich jetzt auch auf die Provinz
Wahlen heute niederschlägt Florian neu
handberichtet
schon die erste Hochrechnung an diesem
Abend lässt sie ausrasten ein Dorf im
Osten der Niederlande vor einigen
Minuten Wahlparty der Bauern
Bürgerbewegung einer Partei die es bei
der letzten Provinz Wahl nicht einmal
gab und die nach ersten Zahlen in
mehreren Provinzen aus dem Stand heraus
stärkste Kraft wird es ist nichts
weniger als ein politisches Erdbeben
und es ist die Geschichte eines
Kulturkampfs um Klimaschutz darüber wie
sowohl der Klimawandel aber eben auch
der Klimaschutz Verlierer produzieren
und wie Politik diesen Konflikt nicht
löst es geht um Viehhalter wie Jois Bolk
388 Tiere sein Hof direkt an
Naturschutzgebiet einer von vielen die
womöglich bald dicht machen müssen für
immer
die Landwirtschaft ist doch ein
wichtiger Teil unseres Zusammenlebens
und das zerstört man nur weil man mit
Scheuklappen alleine auf dem Stickstoff
schaut ähm
allein Stickstoff kein Land in Europa
produziert pro Hektar so viel davon wie
das kleine Land das die Welt ernährt
Kunstdünger und Gülle aus der
Massentierhaltung erzeugen Stickstoff
was Böden Gewässer Naturschutzgebiete
bedroht lange bekannt doch erst als
Gerichte 2019 sie dazu zwingen
Welt die Regierung der stickstoffausstoß
soll bis 2030 um die Hälfte sinken 3.000
Höfe werden dafür schließen müssen
es ist der Startschuss für eine wutwelle
der Bauern die seitdem das Land
erschüttert und die auch diesen
Wahlkampf dominiert hat gestern abend
letzte TV-Debatte vor dem Studio wütende
Bauern und im Studio Caroline von der
Plaz von der Bauern Bürgerbewegung die
sich wie stets als Stimme aus dem Volk
präsentiert
in unserem Land und wir wollen gemeinsam
schauen wie soll die Niederlande 2050
aussehen wer braucht wie viel Platz
ihre Bewegung ist längst ein
Sammelbecken für alle die die da oben
ablehnen immer dabei die niederländische
Fahne allerdings auf dem Kopf oben blaue
Stadt rot man lehnt den Staat wie er ist
ab und trifft sich dabei mit
Rechtspopulisten vom Schlager eines
Pferd Wilders
die Zeiten dürften ungemütlicher werden
nach diesem Abend für die Regierung von
premier markröte und die Geschichte ist
wohl auch ein Lehrstück für Länder denen
solche Debatten noch bevorstehen
der wichtigsten Lektionen ist doch man
darf diese Debatten nicht aussitzen je
länger man wartet desto mehr wird es
Schmerzen
ob die Bauern Bürgerbewegung die
stickstoffregeln stoppen kann ist längst
nicht ausgemacht die niederländische
Politik aber haben sie bereits verändert
und mit der deutschen Klimapolitik geht
es jetzt in den Nachrichten weiter Heinz
der Ausstoß von Treibhausgasen in
Deutschland ist nach Berechnungen des
Umweltbundesamtes im vergangenen Jahr
zurückgegangen aber er muss noch stärker
sinken um die Klimaziele der
Bundesregierung zu erreichen sagte der
Präsident des Umweltbundesamtes Messner
bei der Vorstellung der vorläufigen
Zahlen in Berlin demnach ging der
Ausstoß der Treibhausgase 2022 um 1,9%
zurück notwendig wären aber jährlich
sechs Prozent als Sorgenkind sieht
Messner den Verkehrssektor
US-Verteidigungsminister Osten und sein
russischer Kollege schuigu haben in
einem Telefonat über den Zwischenfall
mit einer US-Drohne und russischen
Kampfjets über dem Schwarzen Meer
gesprochen Austin sagt der anschließend
die USA würden weiterhin fliegen wo ist
das internationale Recht erlaube
Russlands Botschafter in Washington war
auf dem US-Militär dagegen inakzeptable
Aktionen in unmittelbarer Nähe der
russischen Grenzen vor
die Türkei hat nach Angaben des
finnischen Präsidenten ihre Entscheidung
zum nato-beitrittswunsch Finnlands
getroffen nenne es tut heute mit er habe
eine Einladung für Freitag in die Türkei
angenommen um bei der Verkündung der
Entscheidung dabei zu sein die Türkei
hat sich dem von Schweden und Finnland
angestrebten NATO-Beitritt bisher
entgegengestellt allerdings verdichteten
sich zuletzt die Anzeichen dass die
Türkei nun zunächst einen Beitritt
Finnlands zustimmen könnte
schwedensministerpräsident Christa Sonne
heute zu Besuch in Berlin erklärte dass
ihm ein gemeinsamer Beitritt zum
gleichen Zeitpunkt lieber wäre aber er
respektiere voll und ganz dass die
Türkei ihre eigenen Entscheidungen
treffen er erwarte eine Ratifizierung
des beitrittsgesucht seines Landes nach
den Wahlen in der Türkei
Bundeskanzler Scholz bekräftigte dass
sich Deutschland für einen schnellen
NATO-Beitritt der beiden skandinavischen
Länder einsetzt
Bundespräsident Steinmeier hat heute mit
Estland ein weiteres Land an der
nato-ostflanke besucht und war dort auch
auf der Luftwaffenbasis Emmerich wo seit
Anfang dieses Monats deutsche und
britische Chats in gemischten Staffeln
zur Luftraumüberwachung im Einsatz sind
anschließend sprach Steinmeier in
Tallinn mit dem ethnischen Präsidenten
alakaris der betonte wie wichtig
Deutschlands Rolle in der kollektiven
Verteidigung der NATO sei
in der türkischen Erdbebenregion leben
noch immer viele Menschen in Zelten und
Notunterkünften und nun haben heftige
Regenfälle die Gegend überschwemmt
besonders betroffen war die Region San
leopar die Wassermassen verwandelten
Straßen in Flüsse rissen Fahrzeuge mit
sich mindestens 14 Menschen kamen ums
Leben noch immer werden Menschen
vermisst in den kommenden Tagen soll es
weiter regnen
es gäbe wahrscheinlich nicht so viele
amerikanische anwaltsserien oder
Hollywood Klassiker wie die zwölf
Geschworenen wenn im Justizsystem der
USA Geschworenen Gerichte nicht zu einer
große Rolle spielen würden die Jury zu
überzeugen die Diskussionen hinter
verschlossenen Türen all das liefert
natürlich Stoff für Drama in Deutschland
haben wir solche Geschworenen Gerichte
nicht aber auch in unserem Strafrecht
gibt es ja leihenrechte die schaffen die
mit am Richtertisch sitzen dafür
genügend Freiwillige zu finden die das
fünf Jahre lang machen ist allerdings
schwierig und teils melden sich Leute
die man lieber nicht im Rechtssystem der
Bundesrepublik sieht
aktuell werden wieder rund 60.000 Chefin
gesucht für die Amtszeit ab 2024
Amtsgericht Erfurt eine Richterin zwei
schöfferin es geht um Raub und
Körperverletzung das haben die
ehrenamtlichen Richterinnen erst kurz
vorher erfahren um neutral in die
Verhandlung zu gehen wir treffen die
Entscheidung dann aus dem Bauch heraus
so wie wir der Meinung sind wieder
Verfahren gelaufen ist natürlich müssen
wir uns an die rechtlichen Bedingungen
auch halten Chefin wie Christiane Hof
sollen ihre Lebenserfahrung einbringen
bei gleichem Stimmrecht wie
Berufsrichter ein Ehrenamt mit
Aufwandsentschädigung und wenigen
Voraussetzungen bei Amtsantritt müssen
Bewerber zwischen 25 und 69 Jahre alt
sein die deutsche Staatsangehörigkeit
besitzen die deutsche Sprache
beherrschen und sie dürfen keine
Vorstrafen haben
sie noch Volkshochschule Jena
anwerbeabend wie derzeit bundesweit der
Staat sucht händeringend 60.000
freiwillige seit Wochen hält Marco
goshin Vorträge über das Amt dass er
selbst inner hat die Bewerberzahl steigt
aber es ist deutlich weniger als vor
fünf Jahren noch vor Corona für die
Bewerbungen sind die Kommunen zuständig
10 bis 12 Sitzungen haben Chefin im Jahr
viel Verantwortung und auch Bedenken in
Anbetracht mancher schwere von solchen
Fällen ob man dem psychisch sozusagen so
vieles Zeug dagegen hat oder ob das dann
dann doch vielleicht länger an einem
knabbern muss die Wahrheitsfindung und
die Neutralität also wirklich
vorurteilsfrei an alles heranzugehen und
zu schauen
alles aus den verschiedenen Perspektiven
zu sehen ich kann mir das gut vorstellen
weil ich mich schon damit beschäftigt
habe mit dem Thema schon lange und jetzt
bin ich nicht mehr berufstätig jetzt
hätte ich auch die Zeit dafür
problematisch laut Bundesamt für
Verfassungsschutz rufen vereinzelt auch
rechte Gruppierungen die
rechtsextremistische kleinspartei freie
Sachsen zu Bewerbungen auf in den
letzten Jahren auch die AFD im Januar
setzte das Landgericht Erfurt eine
Chefin ein die unter anderem Rechte
Demos mit organisiert hat Marco goshin
appelliert an die Verfassungstreue und
den Eid den auch leidenrichter leisten
tun Sie das bitte nur wenn sie ohne
jeden Vorbehalt auf unserem Werten
stehen auf den Werten des Rechtsstaates
und auf den Werten der Demokratie das
will Bundesjustizminister Buschmann in
einem Gesetz neu festschreiben die
Forderung ist natürlich dass die
beabsichtigte Gesetzesänderung zügig
umgesetzt wird und das die beteiligten
Behörden so viel wie möglich Sorgfalt
bei der Prüfung der Bewerber einen Tag
legen
Amtsgericht Erfurt ist nach drei
verhandlungsstunden Verkündung
[Musik]
Christiane Hof will weitermachen als
Chefin es ist das höchste Ehrenamt in
Deutschland und man kann der
Gesellschaft dafür zurückgeben
für ein Urteil im Namen des Volkes noch
wenige Wochen läuft die Bewerbungszeit
dazu gibt es nachher im heute-journal
Update noch ein Gespräch mit der
Justizministerin von Thüringen
bei dir geht es jetzt mit dem Blick auf
die Finanzmärkte weiter es ist eine
bislang turbulente Börsenwoche eines der
Top-Themen heute die Schweizer Großbank
Kredit Suisse wie ist da der Stand der
Dinge ja bei dem Geldhaus hat es schon
länger finanziell gekriselt innerhalb
von drei Jahren hat die Credit Suisse
fast 90% ihres Börsenwertes eingebüßt in
der europäischen Bankenlandschaft gilt
sie aber als Einzelfall der saudische
Großaktionär die Saudi Nationalbank hat
nun angekündigt der Kredit Suisse kein
weiteres Kapital mehr zu geben und das
sorgt zusätzlich für Misstrauen bei
Banken und Anlegern auch in Deutschland
Frankreich Spanien und Italien wurden
heute Bankaktien aus den Depots geworfen
Papiere der Credit Suisse verlieren zum
Handelsschluss 24% hierzulande büßen die
Aktien der Deutschen Bank und der
Commerzbank rund 9 % ein auch der
deutsche Aktienmarkt entsprechend
schwach der DAX verliert heute knapp 500
Punkte und steht am Ende bei
14.735 Zählern Volkswirte beschwichtigen
aber und sind sich einig eine
Wiederholung der Bankenkrise wie nach
der Lehman Pleite gäbe es nicht die
Schweizer Notenbank hat der Credit
Suisse auch bereits Liquidität
zugesichert und morgen steht die
Zinsentscheidung der Europäischen
Zentralbank an das ist zu erwarten die
Europäische Zentralbank wird wohl
ungeachtet dieser jüngsten Turbulenzen
an ihrem bisherigen Kurs der Zinswende
festhalten morgen könnte sie den
Leitzins zum sechsten Mal in Folge
Anheben von einem halben Prozentpunkt
morgen ist dieses Mal die Rede denn die
EZB erwartet eine weiterhin hohe
Inflation der sie mit steigenden Zinsen
den Garaus machen möchte allerdings
bremst sie damit auch die ohnehin
schwächelnde Konjunktur aus sind vielen
Dank
in Neapel ist vor dem Champions League
Spiel gegen Eintracht Frankfurt zu
schweren Ausschreitungen gekommen es kam
zu Jahrzehnen in der Stadt Hooligans
griffen mit Tischen Stühlen und
Feuerwerkskörpern Einsatzkräfte an ein
Polizeiauto wurde in Brand gesetzt im
Vorfeld war aus Sorge vor
Ausschreitungen von italienischen
Behörden ein Stadionverbot für Frankfurt
Fans verhängt worden dennoch reisten
einige hundert nach Italien
über Neapel und die anderen Achtelfinale
berichtet der Sportstudio Champions
League um 23 Uhr
beim letzten Abfahrtsrennen der Saison
in Andorra standen gleich zwei deutsche
Rennläufer auf dem Podest womit Baumann
wurde mit fast perfekten Rennen zweiter
sein Teamkollege andreas Sander landete
mit 4 Hundertstel dahinter auf Platz 3
gewonnen hat der Österreicher Vincent
kriechmayr
und jetzt die Zahlen vom Lotto am
Mittwoch sie lauten wie immer ohne
Gewähr 3 17 19 34 39 44 Superzahl 8
weitere Gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto.zdf.de und ZDF Text auf Seite 557
ohne Wissenschaft kein Fortschritt das
gilt ja für praktisch alle Bereiche über
die wir gerade auch Nachrichtensendungen
berichten Klimawandel Wassermangel
hatten wir ja heute wieder oder der
ganze medizinische Bereich in dem
unermüdlich geforscht wird insofern ist
es schon immer wieder auch faszinierend
zu sehen womit sich die Wissenschaftler
und Wissenschaftlerinnen befassen die
mit dem Leibniz-Preis ausgezeichnet
werden der ist ja quasi so etwas wie ein
deutscher Nobelpreis heute war die
Verleihung Andreas linke stellt uns zwei
der Preisträger vor ein Mediziner und
einen Architekten
neues bauen mit Harz getränkte
flachsphase von digital gesteuerten
Robotern aufgebracht ein Bauteil
entsteht es ist ein Stück des neuen
Pavillons jetzt im Freiburger
Botanischen Garten zu sehen ohne die
klassischen Baumaterialien wie Stahl und
Beton
entwickelt vom Team um den Stuttgarter
Architekturprofessor Achim Menges
letztendlich kann die Flachsfaser
tatsächlich ein Ersatz sein für
normalerweise industriell hergestellte
mit hohem Energieeinsatz hergestellte
bauwerkstoffe wie Stahlelemente
Betonbauteile
wie macht das eigentlich die Natur ist
der Ansatz der Stuttgarter forsche in
Bezug auf Festigkeit und auf Bewegung
Fassadenelemente die selbstständig
Öffnen oder Schließen je nach Temperatur
aus Holzschichten
in den Teil selbst nutzt man eigentlich
die natürlichen Eigenschaften des Holzes
zu quälen und zu schwinden und in der
Art und Weise wie die Holzschichten
gefügt werden kann man das tatsächlich
in das Material einprogrammieren wie
sich nachher das Bauteil in der echten
Welt verhalten soll
in einer echten Welt die sich verändert
und die ein bauen mit besserer
Umweltbilanz gut vertragen kann daran
arbeitet Achim Menges
unter dem Mikroskop eine Krebszelle die
alte Methode der Diagnose sozusagen
durch das Team von Professor Stephan
Pfister am kindertumorzentrum in
Heidelberg sucht vor allem nach den
molekular genetischen Grundlagen
unterschiedliche Krebsarten
was wir gefunden haben ist letztendlich
dass bestimmte chemische Veränderungen
an der DNA also am Erbgut des Tumors und
ziemlich genau sagen können aus welchen
Geweben oder aus welchen Zellen jeder
Tumor entstanden ist und damit können
wir jetzt extrem gut
tumorenklassifizieren
KI gestützt automatisiert
identifizierten sie über 100
unterschiedliche Typen von
kinderirntumoren die WHO hat diese
Klassifikation inzwischen übernommen die
genaue die tumor-art und ihre Mutation
erkannt ist umso genauer und damit
schonende können dort Medikamente
eingreifen
diese Mutation trägt ja nur der Tumor
und die Tumorzellen und nicht alle
normalen Zellen außerhalb des Thomas
deswegen kam eben sehr viel spezifischer
die Tumorzellen attackieren und nicht so
sehr andere Zellen des Körpers am Ende
steht eine bessere und gleichzeitig
schonendere Krebstherapie und eine von
zehn leibniz-reisen 2023
das was von uns ist folgt das
auslandsjournal heute unter anderem mit
einem Bericht aus Großbritannien wo das
Gesundheitswesen gerade praktischen die
Knie gibt und im heutigen Update mit
Wolf schmidium 0:55 sehen sie noch ein
Gespräch mit dem ukrainischen
Botschafter in Deutschland olexima KEF
und unsere morgen wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter derzeit findet in
Bonn ein Kongress zur Ernährung statt
auch unser Essen schadet dem Klima
besonders kritisch der weltweite
Fleischkonsum er hat sich in den
vergangenen 20 Jahren mehr als
verdoppelt etwa drei Viertel der
globalen landwirtschaftlichen Nutzfläche
wird für Tierhaltung und vor allem für
den Anbau von Futtermitteln genutzt der
Aufwand für die Rindermast ist besonders
hoch dazu kommt dass diese vielen Tiere
das schädliche Treibhausgas mit Haaren
ausstoßen was zur Erde Erhitzung
beiträgt weniger Fleisch bei der
Ernährung würde also weniger
Treibhausgase bedeuten und die Erhitzung
einschränken dazu könnten mehr Menschen
ernährt werden denn es gäbe mehr Fläche
um Getreide Gemüse und Früchte zum
Verzehr anzubauen
kommen wir vom Klima zum Wetter und im
südostdeutschlands bildet sich Nebel
hier kann überfriedene Nässe zu Glätte
führen an den Alpen fallen einige
Schneeflocken auch dort kann es glatt
werden sonst aber ist es größtenteils
aufgeklärt bei tiefsten Temperaturen bis
-6 Grad nach Südosten und plus drei Grad
im Westen aber oft wird es frostig sein
morgen ziehen einige kompakte Wolken
über den Nordwesten und es tröpfelt
etwas raus viel wird es nicht sein nach
Osten hin gibt's viel Sonnenschein bei
höchsten Temperaturen bis zu 16 Grad im
Südwesten am kühlsten Richtung
Schleswig-Holstein bei 6 Grad die
nächsten Tage ein paar Schauer vor allem
am Freitag im Norden bis zu 21 Grad ein
schöner Abend